Okay, we have broken submissions. We can no longer submit
to ASCII Chan. I submit something, but we're only seeing
the cached page. So, so here's what happened. What we
did is, we made a request to ASCII Chan, who
made a query to the database, which came back with
a response. And then ASCII Chan Store that result of
that query in a cache. So now I've got all
of our artwork in our cache, and we use the
data in that cache to send the result back to
the user. Now when we submitted a new piece of art
to ASCII Chan, we wrote that art to the database, and
then we redirected the user back to the front page. The
user then requests to the front page again. At which
point ASCIIchan said, well, the data's already in the cache. I
don't need to check the database. And, return the value from
the cache again, straight to the user, without the new value.
This is a problem. It means now, submissions are still
working. They're going to the database. But because of the new
cache that we added. All of our requests are bouncing
off the cache and the cache isn't getting updated which is
resulting in it appearing as though submissions are broken which
brings us to our next quiz. How can we fix our
stale cache problem and stale cache of course refers to
the fact that our cache is stale. We submitted new content
to our database and our cache is now out
of date. That's referred to as having A stale cache.
Should we improve our cache to automatically expire things after
some time? After we submit, should we just clear the
cache? Or after we submit, should we update the
cache? Or don't cache at all? That's not going to work.
And we should find a different solution. There are multiple
good answers in here. Check all of them that apply.